president Trump is hailing an agreement
between the leaders of North and South
Korea in their historic summit the
president declared in a tweet this
morning this Korean War to end
he said Americans quote should be very
proud of what is taking place in Korea
North Korean leader Kim jong-un and
South Korean president moon jae-in
pledged to remove nuclear weapons from
the Korean Peninsula they also agreed to
turn the demilitarized zone between
their countries into a quote genuine
peace zone and stop all hostile
activities Kim started the stomach
overnight by crossing the DMZ into the
South the first North Korean leader to
do that the summit sets the stage for an
expected meeting between Kim and
president Trump Michael Morell CBS News
senior national security contributor is
here with us again he spent more than
three decades at the CIA becoming the
director of intelligence deputy director
and acting director also with us the CBS
News military and homeland security
analyst sandy Winnefeld a retired navy
admiral and former vice chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff good morning so
suffice it to say we have the best
people here with us in the morning to
talk about North Korea we are so glad
because there's so much to talk about
let me start with you Admiral Winnefeld
the news this morning they're talking
about the official end of the Korean War
what would that mean well first of all I
would tell you that Michael and I both
last summer when it looked like war was
gonna break out on the north on the
Korean Peninsula we were saying take a
deep breath everybody it's not going to
happen now that it looks like peace is
gonna break out on the North on the
Korean Peninsula we're saying the same
thing this is a very positive step but
there's a long way to go to get where
the peninsula needs to be to truly be a
peaceful place Admiral dough was the
kind of over militarization talk helpful
in getting us to this moment and is it
and will it be helpful going forward in
terms of US military activity around
North Korea well you know I think both
sides were coming at each other sort of
talking past each other and that we feel
that and to a degree are correct that we
put a lot of economic pressure and
military pressure on North Korea to come
to the table here North Korea as Michael
pointed out earlier in the broadcast
said you know they're thinking hey we've
got nuclear weapons now and we're
dragging the u.s. to the table so both
sides feel that they're there
a position of strength and it's gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out so
Michael which of the United States be
looking for now because you look at the
optics they're both crossing back and
forth which is a lay person you're
sitting watching saying this looks very
impressive what we have to do now is
prepare the president for the summit
with Kim and to prepare him for that he
have to be very clear with the president
here's what North Korea's objectives are
and here's how Kim is going to try to
pursue them and here's how you need to
deal with that so that should be the
focus right now into the conversations
with the president and Kim jong-un be
trusted now should he be given the
benefit of the doubt both of you no no
no the Kim regimes so three of them now
have shown over and over again a
willingness to make an agreement and
then either break that agreement or
cheat on that agreement so whatever we
agree to there's got to be a very tough
verification regime the president has a
new national security team just in the
last month he has a new Secretary of
State he has a new national security
adviser in the past though president
Trump has said North Korea must scrap
its weapons program before any relief of
sanctions do you think he's going to be
able to hold the line on that well I
think that just what happened what just
happened was very clearly choreographed
to try to set up a more gradual process
where there may be some sanctions relief
there may be some compromises by North
Korea on its weapons program and I think
the vital question will be whether
President Trump can declare victory by
still allowing him a little bit more
time to get rid of his nuclear weapons
program if he's even willing to do that
Wow while he builds confidence in the
survival of his regime I was just there
in June with with president moon where
he talked about these bilateral talks
but I think for us to remember we have
30,000 US troops there we have a huge
American commitment on the Korean
Peninsula what does it mean for them
those military families well I think
even if there's a peace agreement we
will probably remain on the peninsula
just to be a buttress for South Korea to
build their confidence that this is not
a you know
Mirage just as we have troops in Europe
and I think we will probably be on the
North Korean or the Korean Peninsula for
quite some time
like the Iran nuclear deal critics of
that said it didn't wipe out the Iranian
program they could still start at some
time in the future given the criticism
of what people call half-measures in
Iran how should we think about a deal
that is likely to fall short of complete
ending of all nuclear anything in North
Korea so the Republicans and I don't
want to get political here but the
Republicans have been critical of the
Iran deal saying we didn't get enough
for the leverage that we had and we
didn't include all the other malign
activity on the part of the Iranians
right we have the same issue here when
President Trump sits down with Kim is he
just going to talk about the nuclear
issue or is he going to bring up all the
other bad activity that the North
Koreans do from cyber to to
assassinations of individuals outside of
North Korea to human rights abuses is he
going to bring all those issues in as
well to the death of otto warmbier yes
right I mean the beating death of Ottawa
here you know there are two other things
that came out of the actual communique
that were interesting one they talked
about unification but no discussion of
what that really looks like and when you
consider think about South Africa all of
the crimes that were committed by Kim
how does that get worked out and the
other thing is there was a discussion
about potential trilateral talks between
the u.s. and North Korea in South Korea
or quadrilateral talks between the US
China and South Korea doesn't say
anything about Russia or Japan and
especially he's going to feel cut out in
President Trump claimed credit here that
we've gotten to this point so far I
think he does get some credit he's put
unprecedented pressure on North Korea
both militarily and economically by the
same token North Korea feels they put
unprecedented pressure on us by
achieving a nuclear weapons capability
but I would give the president a good
credit for placing that pressure on the
North he'll brings up an important point
cuz the South Korean foreign minister is
giving Trump a lot of credit this
morning and it was Trump who said that
Obama's the Obama administration's
policy of strategic patience was a
failure and it was time to actually
begin these bilateral sort of
negotiations this is that that has
brought us to this point both North
Korea and South Korea
a huge incentive right to get to to get
to the Kim Trump summit
South Korea's incentive is they were
they were deeply afraid that a military
confrontation was going to break out
North Korea wants to get there because
it wants to turn their nuclear leverage
into sanctions relief and all of this
very carefully choreographed goodwill
that's been created over the last
several months beginning with the
Olympics in' and ending up with this
particular summit it's going to almost
make that meeting between Trump and Kim
alakh who has the upper hand in that
meeting going into the meeting now
that's gonna be a very interesting
question I do think that if President
Trump doesn't hear what he wants to hear
and he walks away he's gonna have to do
it gracefully and return to the status
quo rather than threatening to use force
even more robustly the best the best
outcome of a Kim Trump summit is a set
of goals and objectives for further
talks by lower-level officials the worst
outcome is that those talks between
Trump and Kim break down right and and
and and and in a not positive way then
where do you go after that all right
Michael Morell you have the last word
Admiral Winnefeld to see I think North
said it best we are the best people the
table for this topic
what are you all experts or something
thank you very much like decades of
experience thank you very much